hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
bonsoir voici un nouvel épisode commence
c'est d'ici que le show de kopitar ici
nous allons pénétrer points
[ __ ] nous allons pénétrer les
coulisses du pam une chaude lapica
quêteurs nous voilà à présent d'angola
nov
pardon nous voilà devant la sacro-sainte
loge de baba que l'on a peu de la casbah
de baba dans sa langue maternelle au
pardon casbah de baba dans sa langue
maternelle
rabat 15 bat de baba dans sa langue
maternelle libyenne
c'est ici que c'est ghislaine à nous
fait découvrir tout ce qu'il nous faut
c'est en effet une personnalité était
assis ici sur une charge en formica le
traquenard était simple la table ce
louvain la table s'ouvrait et un groupe
venu visco a put 1 1
les tables étaient bien les décos [ __ ]
c'est un art d'être comédien
[Musique]